[Music]
welcome once again to another edition of
i' like to know our Bible question and
answer program that we have the pleasure
of bringing to you each and every week
and we are so happy to do so you know
they I'm reading a book that talks about
dopamine and dopamine is the feel-good
hormone it's it's a hormone that that is
released when you're doing something
that that you like to do when you're
involved in exercise those kind of
things and I think that that um I'd like
to know is sort of a a dopamine release
for all of us we we like to do it and
any preacher who who loves the Lord and
spends time with the Lord number one
likes to study about the Lord likes to
preach about the Lord and also likes to
answer questions about the Lord and so
that's what make this this program such
fun for us because we get to answer your
questions it gives us a chance to study
the word of God which we love to do but
it also gives us a chance to understand
and to to clue into those things that
are bothering you that are bothering the
body of Christ those questions that you
have around the world and it is our
pleasure to come to you and to answer
these questions now I am CA Murray I'm
in the pleasure of Pastor David Salazar
and pastor Steven bour uh two colleagues
in Ministry dare I say our president and
our director of our Latino operations
and we are thankful for both of these
individuals want to give you the contact
information right right off the bat
because should you want to get a
question in we invite you to uh write us
at
tvom tv.org that's
tvsm as in Mary
tv.org and we will get to your questions
just as soon as we can and we promise
you to answer those questions from the
word of God if indeed an answer can be
found Pastor David if you would ask the
Lord's blessing on us in prayer we're
going to launch right out in our program
today
certainly Heavenly Father we thank you
once again Lord for allowing us to come
before your throne of grace and for
granting us the opportunity to share
from your word uh the questions or the
answers that are uh that are presented
there for those questions that our
friends are sending in we ask now that
you will give us a portion of the holy
spirit so that we may understand what
your uh word has has for us instored and
we may share not our own thoughts not
our own ideas but the ideas and the
thoughts that come from you we pray this
in Jesus name amen amen amen gentlemen
our first question is one of those
questions that there is no specific text
in the Bible to say thou shalt Thou
shalt not so we've got to draw from
overriding biblical principles and of
course your own experience with the Lord
so this is coming to us from Taylor
Arlington or Arlington Taylor I'm not
sure which but thank you for the
question he wants to know is it okay for
Christians to go to the beach currently
in this day and age basically is it okay
right now to go to the beach in the
current times that we are living in I'm
not saying that the beach is bad but
from my personal experience I feel con
convinced that one should be be mindful
of when they go or not because of the
environment so he's kind of answering
his question a little bit in his in his
his in his question but let let's
ruminate on that for just a minute
gentlemen um I'll start with you Pastor
bour what's in your mind what's in your
heart I would recommend for him to find
a desolate
Beach yes yeah you know there's nothing
wrong with going to the beach certainly
uh you know God made the ocean and U
I've gone to the beach many times it's
very recreational very
refurbishing uh so I think that what
he's talking about is what you observe
on the beach precisely uh you know the
women and men also who are scantily
clothed uh to be blunt I think that's
what he's referring to I have a text
here uh in Isaiah chapter 33 that has
the principle it says is um speaking
about those who are going to be in the
presence of a God who is a consuming
fire He Who Walks righteously and speaks
uprightly he who despises the gain of
oppressions who gestures with his hands
refusing bribes who stops his ears from
hearing of Bloodshed and shuts his eyes
from seeing
evil so in other words if if you go to
the beach and you're enticed to observe
what is contrary to God's will then find
another Beach or don't go to the beach
yes go walk in the midst of
nature Pastor David well you know in
adding to what Pastor Bora is mentioning
the the main problem is not the place
necessarily because you can actually uh
for example we live here in California
and there is a beautiful mountain and
park Yi uh National Park
you have to go up in the mountains and
in the summer it's it's it's a lot of
beautiful streams and there's some parts
of lakes and whatnot in that area and
people go and they hike and they're
you're in the mountains but some people
will you know take their clothes off and
go in swimsuits and whatever so you
might be exposed to the same environment
even if you're not in the beach
necessarily so you have to be mindful
and you have to understand that it's not
the place necessarily the problem it's
the environment the time so you know if
you are going during a big holiday to
any location where there's water most
likely you're going to have individuals
who are not properly dressed who are
undressing too much if you will and so
you might want to avoid perhaps
gathering in places that have water in
those in those moments on you know
there's a lot of people but to say that
a place particularly is bad and he
actually answer the question says you
know it's not bad but if it's in an
environment and it's a holiday and it's
a vacation spot a hot spot you know you
are better to avoid uh ultimately there
is beautiful places to go in the world
that still kind of help us to connect
with god sister white for example she
loved the beach she enjoyed going to
have picnics at the beach and and you
know these kind of things but back then
obviously was different than today I
would not recommend a young man going to
a place that is popular like a you know
South Beach in Miami or something like
that you you would not go there because
it's just the music the environment
everything is conducive for to you know
to appeal to the to the flesh to the
carnal nature of us and therefore it
would not be necessarily a good place to
go but uh finding Recreation and places
where you can meditate with in God's you
know uh character in his love his
creative power you got to find places
like that and maybe there may be oceans
there may be a place in the beach there
may be places in the mountains but you
have to be more selective and another
thing is there's a lot of people who
live in in Islands who live by the ocean
you can't say you know to those people
well you are in a Mistake by living next
to the ocean know that's their life but
I'm sure that someone that lives in the
ocean or is near the beach knows how
beautiful how how wonderful that is how
how refreshing it might be for their own
experience uh so I I think that you have
to be very careful in um in not making
this a dogmatic issue but to really just
understand that it's the area and the
environment that can create a problem
and if you see that to be the case then
yes avoid that area and look for
something that's secluded well done
if if you don't want if you don't want
to see anything that is a violation of
principles you would have to walk around
with your eyes
closed and even with you if you walked
around with your eyes closed you wouldd
still have your
brain you know your computer MH can be
worse than going to the beach oh yeah
now they there's all kinds of junk on
the computer mhm you know I don't watch
that stuff but I certainly have R and
watched on television what they have to
say about that and uh so you know just
depriving yourself of the beach cuz you
don't want to see anything objectionable
but at home you're looking at things
that are objectionable on your computer
there you go or even when you go for
your morning walk yeah you know
sometimes I go for my War morning walk
and there's women that go out to walk
and and you know they're uh Dressed in
sports gear and you know you'd have to
walk around with your eyes closed yeah
just just just ask the Lord in prayer MH
to please keep your eyes from looking at
things that are objectionable in a
violation of principle MH and then apply
it to your personal life well said well
said amen I remember back in Ellen
White's time there was a discussion over
the American costume uh and there was a
question whether women should have their
ankles showing you know that was that
was the height of in you know indecorous
uh Behavior Uh if if if ell and W were
allow to see some of the things that
people jog in today she'd die of a heart
attack she'd die of a heart attack um
it's just you know we've come so far uh
so the text that comes to my mind is is
Job chapter 31 verse one I have made a
covenant with my eyes he said I have
made a covenant with my eyes why then
shall I look upon a young woman so
that's not only a beach as you well said
you've got to watch watch what you watch
on TV things can pop up on your computer
so you've got to make a cover in your
mind that there are certain places I'm
not going to go certain things I'm not
going to do I'll do this quickly in
Panama I don't know if this is any other
Latino country in Panama they have a a
custom uh for Christmas and New Year
they they cook all day Christmas Eve and
New Year's Eve they eat late at night
maybe 9 10 11 o'clock then they go
outside and everybody shoots off
fireworks till about 1 or 2 o'clock in
the morning and then everybody gets up
at 5:00 and goes to the beach I mean
Town's empty out everybody goes to the
beach yeah we were for a while part of
that herd but we realized we couldn't we
couldn't go to the beach during that
time first of all it's too crowded uh
the music was too loud and then
everybody was half-dressed I mean we
just you know you'd have to just spend
your day looking into the sun you know
there was nothing you could do so so
Irma and I and her sister and we sat we
say you know we can't do this we just we
just we can't yeah uh we we can't do
this so you've got to develop a little
discernment so not only the beach your
television your computer your iPad
whatever You' got to make a covenant
with God that there are certain things
I'm not going to do Psalms chapter 101:3
I will set no worthless or Wicked thing
before my eyes so if if it's going to
cause you to sin if it's going to put
your mind in the wrong place then you
just have to triage the times you go you
can go to the beach if you can in the
evening when there's not a crowd there
and you can do that but when people
start piling in in very
you're going to run into some visual
problems and uh you got to pray to the
Lord so as both men have said going to
the beach is not wrong per se but um if
your hand causes you or eyes cause you
to sin you got to you got to stop it you
don't want to have your relationship
with God in any way destroyed amen amen
so thank you so very much for that
question now Tristan uh this is from
Australia so thank You Tristan from Down
Under
uh Pastor Bor and the panel I have a
question about baptism here we go what
is the biblical position on who can
perform
baptism is it in the case that it must
be an ordained minister baptizing into a
specific church or can any genuine
disciple of Christ baptize into the body
of Christ free of a
specific denomination now there's
there's a lot of things in here is sort
of unpack because
um of some qualifications that she's
made in in the question uh ordained
minister genuine
Christian Body of Christ specific church
so we've got to sort of walk our way
through all of these
things okay well I'll start and I'm sure
you and Pastor B will have many much
more to say but first of all I would
like to go uh to the book of M Matthew
and I know that a lot of Disciples of
Christ a lot of Christian Believers will
take these verses to somewhat say
everybody can baptize and I'm going to
the the the Great Commission that is
given by Jesus to his disciples sure
this is in Matthew 28 verse 18- 20 and
Jesus said came and spake unto them
saying all power is given unto me in
heaven and in Earth go ye B therefore
and teach All Nations baptizing them in
the name of the the father and of the
son and of the Holy Ghost teaching them
to observe all things whatsoever I have
commanded you and lo I Am With You
Always even until the end of the world
Amen so that's how the the verse goes
and so I can imagine that maybe Tristan
has heard or has come to this verse of
of maybe somebody has told him about
this verse and saying you know the Lord
told all these disciples to go and
baptize and teach and all these things
so is that mean everybody can baptize
well I think the main thing the most the
main point in this verse specifically is
that you have to know the truth and you
have to know Jesus and know everything
that he has taught to be able to truly
properly give the sound Doctrine sound
teaching to those who are uh near you
and that is a requirement to be baptized
is other words you can't just baptize
somebody because they just want to
accept Jesus and that's it the teachings
of Christ the doctrines of Jesus have to
be taught for them to truly understand
what it means to follow Jesus so this
already kind of puts puts a lot of of of
difference between uh Christian who has
not received all the knowledge all the
understanding and therefore for example
if somebody gets baptized in another
church another denomination and they
have come to the knowledge of the truth
as we found in the scriptures the
Sabbath The Law of God the Judgment
Second Coming that individual must be
baptized because now she or he
understands or has learned all the
knowledge understanding uh and this is
what for example happened with those
Disciples of John they were baptized by
John but when they receive the knowledge
of Jesus they had to be baptized again
so what so being baptized but just any
denomination any Christian even though
they might be very you know sincere some
of them is not a baptism that is truly
fully done in the sense of what the Lord
meant uh so I think that you know it's
important that a baptism that was
performed in another denomination and
that individual dies without knowing
anymore well the Lord might count that
as as valid because he didn't know any
better but if the knowledge was
available if the truth came to that
individual or the light is received and
that person wants to actually embrace
the truth and be part of God's kingdom
he needs to be baptized under the 7 Day
Adventist Faith so that is you know
because we the church the Adventist
Church is the one that holds all the
doctrines from the word of
God uh as far as who can baptize going
back to the Great Commission yeah in
Matthew
28 Jesus was speaking to his disciples
who were ordained yes that's the Christ
laid his hands upon them right it says
so in Mark chapter 3 right right so he's
giving the command to individuals who
had been ordained now it doesn't it
doesn't mean that um others can't preach
the word and bring those people to
someone who has been aside to perform
baptisms and to officiate the Lord's
supper and so on uh so um the Bible
seems to indicate that those who have
been set aside by the laying on of hands
are the ones that are authorized to do
baptisms although everyone in the church
is responsible to share the message and
bring people to the point of baptism
amen and amen amen and amen um you are
right U parallel with what my thinking
is she says can any genuine disciple of
Christ bapti
well who makes the designation that the
person that wants to do that is a
genuine disciple uh what makes a person
a genuine disciple is that they have
been designated as such by someone who
can make that decision and that's what
Christ did for those 12 his his call was
not an open throw out to everybody it
was to these individuals who were part
of of this select group who were given
charge to teach and to baptize and you
cannot do do one without the other it is
illegitimate to baptize someone and not
give them the rules of the game you know
I'm going to call you a Christian I'm
going to baptize you into Christ but
what does that mean for my behavior how
am I to live after my baptism because
I'm now representing Jesus so it's it's
not fair to to just say okay I'm going
to baptize into Jesus and not give them
a full understanding of what that means
because you've got to change your life
you know you've got to change your walk
your talk your likes your your your
desires all of that has to precede
baptism and to do one before the other
makes it illegitimate because you're
baptizing someone into uh a fellowship
and they don't know what that Fellowship
really means or understands so um uh the
last thing I want to say is once you
teach a person what Christ desires from
them what Christ wants from them it
tends to lead you Pastor and Pastor in
the direction of a specific denom ation
you know you can not just baptize you in
Jesus but if you say God wants me to
keep the Sabbath God wants me to live
clean God wants me to to not deal with
unclean animals well you have got to
find a a faith group that follows those
things so that kind of moves you Pastor
in a direction of a specific
denomination so to just say well I'm
just going to baptize you into Christ I
don't think that's what Christ had in
mind because it it's not legit to the
person who is who is um being baptized
the Adventist Church had this in its
early days there were people going out
and just baptizing people and adding and
speaking any name and there was no
official church group and folk were just
doing all kinds of stuff and we were
coming into a lot of problems because
there was no regulatory body to say if
you're going to be part of this group
you've got to obey these regulations so
they had to sort of regularize their
their Ministry so that when you got
baptized you knew what you were getting
baptized into Pastor you got something
else uh yes
baptism involves two things mhm number
one baptism is Union with Christ
amen and uh that doesn't have anything
directly to do with a denomination as
such MH because there are many many
people in all churches yeah that have
been baptized into Christ for example in
Galatians 3 uh it says in verse 26 for
you are all sons of God through faith in
Christ Jesus for as many of you as were
baptized into Christ have put on Christ
so first of all baptism means Union with
Christ but baptism also means Union with
his church right with his body and
there's where 1 Corinthians chapter uh
12 and verse 13 comes in for by one
Spirit we were all baptized into one
body yes whether Jews or Greeks whether
slaves are free and all have been made
to drink into one spirit so to be honest
with you I've never Lo the liked the
idea of profession of
Faith which we have in the Seventh Day
Adventist Church which you can tell a
person if you were baptized in another
church because you love Jesus Christ uh
you don't have to get baptized by
immersion in the seventh day adven
church I've never particularly cared for
that I try to convince people to
baptized in the water there's something
about being buried in the water and
coming to forth to newness of life and
joining God's Remnant church that
teaches the truth as it is in Jesus and
so I try to convince people that uh that
have been baptized in another
denomination by immersion uh to join the
Seventh Day Adventist Church by
immersion and and I explained to them
baptism your first baptism your union
with Christ I'm sure it was genuine I'm
sure it was true I'm sure that you were
pumped up that you were truly joined
with Christ but you were belong to a
church that wasn't teaching the fullness
of Truth and so and so what I would
recommend is you get baptized again not
to unite with Christ but to make a
public announcement that you are wanting
to join the body of Christ the church
that proclaims the truth as it is in
Jesus amen and I found that most people
that I I approach in that way uh they're
willing to get baptized when because
many their first baptism uh in another
church I mean that was that has
tremendous meaning for them yes so
you're not going to say okay you need to
get baptized again to to unite with
Christ we going to say I already am
United to Christ so that's the way that
I approach it and I think that because
the Bible presents those two points
Union with Christ and Union with the
church uh I think that that's the
direction to go and I also like the
verse that's found in Ephesians 4:5 you
know one Lord One Faith one baptism so
as you mentioned you know you what who
do what do you believe in what church
you believe in you you trust you give
yourself into this is the Lord the
church the faith and then one baptism so
I I also agree with you Pastor B I
believe that most individuals who have
to you know have come to the knowledge
of the truth it's is a better experience
to be baptized into that faith into that
religion if you will in in the Adventist
Faith so that it makes a testament and a
testimony of what it means to truly
understand the principle of knowledge
and understanding and Doctrine be
committed with Christ and and finally
you know one last thing that maybe is is
sort of you know important to mention
here in regards to who can baptize you
know the church has ordained ministers
and and and you might say well what if
anain minister is not around well that's
why you have local Elders who are also
ordained as elders ERS who are also
ordained with the you know blessing of
the hands so that they are actually also
able to do the duty of baptism if
necessary if there's not a pastor amen
well said um the text that you
referenced to uh Acts 19 um I think one
of the dividing lines is as you receive
more truth and more light and that was
the issue there they were baptized into
repentance but they didn't really know
about life in Christ and when they found
out uh living in Jesus they they were
re-baptized again so I think there was
there was not even a church to join in
their first
baptism very very very true again we we
hope that this has been of of of value
to you when I was doing prison ministry
there were many who just just baptized
me in Jesus but they didn't know what
that meant teaching is very much a part
of uh the spiritual discipline before
baptism again our time has fast slipped
into eternity allow me in closing to
wish you Grace and peace to our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ we'll see you again
soon bye-bye and God bless
[Music]